[Music]
jacob is with us hey jacob welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave how you doing great man what's
up
not much so i've got a good problem so
to speak um my wife and i we've been
really good with money ever since we
were married never really had any debt
other than our house
um i had a good opportunity to make some
good money in the past years at work but
recently i took a promotion which kind
of came to pay cut because of the
overtime and so i'm trying to get our
family locked down on budgeting
and i've had some resistance the past
years my wife and it's not because she's
not great with money but she's a
full-time teacher she's mom four kids
runs our house
and so the problem is she pays for a lot
of our miss laney's expenses that are
not like mortgage utilities things of
that nature and so i need her input and
her information help make our budget
work but usually every time i need to
get it she's just so busy it becomes a
little bit of a like a tense
you know conflict between us and it just
stops so i don't know if you had any
advice on how to kind of get your wife
on board when she's busy and she's great
with money but it's hard to make a
budget when you can't get her half of
what she's spending and try to figure
that whole thing out
she's not busy
she is busy but busy is an excuse she
doesn't want you telling her what to do
how much you told me three times how
good she is with money and yet she
doesn't do a budget so she's not good
with money that's also bs how much pay
cut did you take i feel like that that's
coming into play somehow
uh well i worked a ridiculous amount of
overtime in law enforcement and so as
you know the crime rate's been kind of
spiking around the country so i went
from probably the 170 range because of
all the overtime down to about 110.
and
did y'all talk about that extensively
and all the repercussions of that
decision before it happened oh
absolutely um i was in a very uh
high use area of law enforcement and so
i was gone a lot and we kind of realized
there was a certain shelf life with that
and so the promotion was the best way
out of that because it came with a
guaranteed pay increase but i could be
at home a lot more and not you know
getting burnt out so much
yeah
all right cool
well here's the thing and here's the
thing you have been handling all the
money and uh giving her an allowance to
run the household on and she doesn't
want you tinkering in her allowance
so um
the you have to have a bigger vision to
get her to speak into this and the
bigger vision includes her voice counts
her vote counts
she's not going to have things taken
away from her but she is going to hold
herself
accountable
and you both are going to be held
accountable to
the a plan that you put in place to
cause your future to happen
and that is simply we're going to sit
down we're going to sit down and do a
the kids are going to go to bed and
we're going to sit down we're going to
turn off the television and we're going
to have um you know it takes about 45
minutes
a week for the first 90 days and after
that it takes about 20 minutes a week
to keep a budget going so it does not
take that much time this is about more
than time well and the the other thing
jacob and i'll tell you because my
husband and i do this exactly like this
we will decide in advance when we're
going to have that conversation so if he
came to me about anything when i'm in
the middle of putting meals on the table
or wrangling the kids no i'm not that's
not a good time to do that thing because
you are it's all hands on deck when the
kids are up but if you say hey i'd like
for us to work on the budget on sunday
night at eight does that work for you
and she says yes that works for me or no
let's do this time instead and you
literally put it on the counter okay so
i just wanna are we on the same page or
sunday night eight the kids are down
we're gonna we're going to get the
kitchen cleaned up we're going to sit
down and work on this together is that
good for you because
i want your input and because i want us
to be in agreement about where our
future's going we've done a good job to
date but with this pay cut i'm really
nervous and i need your help yeah
and you and you plan it plan when you're
gonna have that conversation and then
you do so then when sunday night comes
like okay here we go
it's just agreed upon it's not in this
in the moment trying to squeeze in a
major conversation when life can be
chaotic so just put it on the calendar
and again like dave said share the why
of it why does this matter
why and how you value her opinion and
it's going to give a different tone to
it that um that will hopefully make it
make it go better yeah you guys have
never agreed on your spending before
you together uh you agreed on the
mortgage stuff and that she got x number
dollars after that to run the household
in quotes
uh whatever that meant to her and you
didn't care what it meant and so but now
you have to care which is good so you're
going to aim at the future a little bit
more detail
and say we're as a couple we're going to
set the vision
for where we want to be in 10 years and
as a couple we're going to decide
what
we have to do to accomplish that vision
yeah the budget would reflect that and
jacob i mean when you're having this
conversation one other thing i'll throw
in there and we're giving you several
several tips here but
ask her
why she doesn't want to do it i i'm a
direct person sometimes i'm like if i
sense resistance be like hey seems like
you don't want to do this just tell me
why she's already told him she's too
busy i know that's not true no but keep
that's what i mean keep pressing say no
like sunday night we're not busy or
whatever time hey is it because you feel
like i'm taking money away is it because
you feel like you don't get to say is it
because you whatever just ask some
open-ended questions and then maybe if
you peel away the layers there the first
answer you might get is she's busy but
then once you keep pressing and and in a
loving way it might be like hey i'm
really scared of what we're you know
what it's going to look like i'm scared
i'm not going to have money for then you
start to be able to solve things at the
root issue which is actually where they
need to be solved it's not this surface
level busy conversation you actually get
to what's really going on so don't be
afraid to ask some of those direct
questions but ask them in love and then
you might find the real answer so you
can start to work at it at that at that
level now from
30 years of doing this
my suspicion is
is that your
it feels like you're taking away some of
her power yeah because this is an area
that she you know you're like asking to
move into her territory this has been
delegated to her and now you're actually
wanting to know what's going on and she
doesn't like you having a voice in it
um and because she's used to running it
and leave me alone and i haven't done a
bad job and there's no reason well there
is a reason we need to do this together
yeah and make a decision together yeah
and uh it can be some of the biggest
fights you have if you don't get through
that it's a big deal very very very
important so folks when you learn to do
a plan together a spending plan together
that's what rachel calls it because she
likes to spend
a spending plan that's all a budget is
you're telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went as a
couple when you are married and you
decide together where you're doing that
you are officially deciding what's
important to you
as a couple
both of you have a say and we join
our values into one and we say as a
couple
we think this is more important than
that
we think
this thing here is a big deal
we want to get both of these done but
this one's going first
and when you start making those
decisions together you create a level of
unity in your relationship that you can
create no other way a budget is unique
in doing that as a marriage
enhancement
tool
this
is the ramsey show